Hollywood es el barrio más famoso del mundo.
Y sí, habéis oído bien, he dicho “barrio”.
Hollywood no es una ciudad, ni siquiera un
pueblo. Se trata de un distrito dentro de
la ciudad de Los Ángeles, con menos de 90.000
habitantes. Sin embargo, es aquí donde se
concentran la mayor parte de las productoras
del cine a nivel internacional.
Y sí, ya sé lo que me vais a decir… “Fonseca,
eso no es cierto… en realidad el lugar que
más películas produce en todo el mundo es
Bollywood, en La India”. Pues sí, tenéis
razón pero hay un detalle que se os escapa.
Aunque la industria del cine hindú produce
más títulos que ninguna otra, el dinero
que generan es prácticamente una broma comparada
con los ingresos de Hollywood.
Pensadlo bien
¿Habéis visto muchas películas de la India?
Probablemente no. Salvo unas pocas excepciones,
casi todas las películas de cine de Bollywood
se venden únicamente en la India. Y lo mismo
ocurre con Nigeria. Nigeria es el segundo
productor de cine en todo el planeta. Pero
estoy seguro de que pocos habréis visto alguna
película hecha en este país.
Es decir, que en términos económicos, Hollywood
es la capital indiscutible del cine.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué os vamos a hablar
de cine en VisualPolitik? ¿Qué tiene que
ver este canal con las películas? Pues mucho.
Porque el hecho de que la industria del entretenimiento
esté concentrada en esta zona tan específica
del mundo tiene una explicación política.
A fin de cuentas ¿Por qué Los Ángeles es
la capital del cine y no lo es Londres o Nueva
York, por ejemplo? Muchos pensaréis que California
siempre ha sido un estado importante dentro
de Estados Unidos, con empresas innovadoras,
universidades de prestigio y famosos paseando
por las calles.
Pero lo cierto es que, a principios
del siglo XX, Los Ángeles apenas tenía 100.000
habitantes. De hecho, las primeras productoras
de cine nacieron en el otro extremo del país,
concretamente en Nueva York. Así que la pregunta
es ¿Por qué decidieron mudarse a Los Ángeles?
¿Qué tenía Hollywood que no tuviera Manhattan?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Sigue siendo
Hollywood la meca del cine? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas. Pero antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
EL ARTE DE LOS INMIGRANTES
La primera pregunta que nos tenemos que hacer
es ¿Quién inventó el cine?... (CORO: ¡LOS
HERMANOS LUMIERE!)
¡Pues no exactamente! Lo que inventaron los
hermanos Lumiere fue el sistema para proyectar
películas en una gran sala. Pero años atrás,
la empresa de Thomas Alva Edison ya había
descubierto un sistema para poder grabar y
reproducir películas cortas, el KINETOSCOPIO.
Se trataba de una máquina donde metías una
moneda y podías ver imágenes en movimiento
a través del visor. Años después, mejoró
el invento para que también pudiera proyectar
imágenes. A diferencia de los Lumiere, Edison
tenía muy claro que el cine era algo más
que un descubrimiento científico: era un
negocio.
“No quiero inventar cosas que no se venden.
Las ventas son una prueba de la utilidad.
Y la utilidad es sinónimo de éxito” –Thomas
Alva Edison
Mientras los Lumiere se limitaron a mostrar
su invento por diferentes ferias internacionales,
Edison se dedicó a venderlo. Su negocio consistía
en vender las máquinas, cobrar una comisión
por utilizarla y, además, suministrar películas
a todos los teatros. Edison llegó a producir
más de 1200 películas.
Y os preguntaréis
¿Qué tipo de cine vendía el señor Edison
a sus clientes? Pues… por sorprendente que
parezca, las primeras películas comerciales
consistían en señoritas quitándose la ropa
¡Tal cual como lo oís!
Sin embargo, el cine daba mucho más de sí.
En pocos años, ciudades como Nueva York o
Chicago se llenaron de salas de cine, los
llamados NICKELODEONS. Aquí te prometían
diversión a un precio mucho más barato que
cualquier otro espectáculo de teatro. Además,
como eran películas mudas, no necesitabas
saber inglés para entenderlas. Eso significa
que el cine se convirtió en el pasatiempo
perfecto para todos esos muchísimos inmigrantes
que llegaban al País de las oportunidades.
Estamos ya en la primera década del siglo
XX.
Francia y, curiosamente, Dinamarca, ya tenían
productoras de cine. Pero ningún otro país
tenía tanto público como Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, Thomas Alba Edison era incapaz
de ver todas las oportunidades que tenía
su invento. A fin de cuentas, se trataba del
clásico Estadounidense blanco y anglosajón,
que en cierto modo, despreciaba a esos inmigrantes.
Por supuesto, estaba encantado de ganar dinero
gracias a ellos. Pero ¿Para qué iba a invertir
en producir películas de calidad? A fin de
cuentas, su empresa tenía el monopolio de
la producción y distribución de cines. Cualquiera
de esos nickeodeons pagaba sus royalties a
la empresa de Edison y, después, compraban
rollos de películas prácticamente al peso,
sin siquiera mirar los argumentos ni los títulos.
A fin de cuentas, nadie pensaba que esos inmigrantes
alemanes, húngaros o italianos iban a apreciar
muchos matices.
Hasta que apareció este señor que véis
en pantalla, CARL LAEMMLE.
Laemmle era uno
de esos inmigrantes alemanes que tenia un
Nickelodeon en Chicago. El negocio le iba
maravillosamene bien. Pero estaba cansado
de tener que pagar tantísimo dinero por las
películas de Edison. Así que se preguntó
¿No podría hacer yo mis propias películas?
Como decimos en VisualPolitik… dicho y hecho.
Laemmle conocía a otros propietarios de salas.
Todos ellos eran inmigrantes, que conocían
bien los gustos y aspiraciones de su público.
Sabían que el cine podía ser algo más que
chistes malos y chicas ligeras de ropa.
Podían crear auténticas estrellas como esas actrices
famosas que salían en los musicales de Broadway.
Estos pioneros del cine fueron los primeros
en poner los nombres de los actores en los
carteles de las películas y en los títulos
de crédito.
De esta forma, conseguían que
muchos otros actores quisieran trabajar con
ellos. Sus películas se hicieron famosas
en un público que venía de distintos países del mundo.
Y por eso a esta productora la llamaron la UNIVERSAL.
Como os podéis imaginar, el éxito de esta
nueva empresa sirvió de inspiración para
muchas otras pequeñas productoras. Por ejemplo,
otro inmigrante húngaro, ADOLPH ZUKOR, también
se asoció con otros dueños de salas de cine
y formó otra productora, la PARAMOUNT PICTURES.
De repente, Nueva York y, en general, la Costa
Este de EEUU se estaba convirtiendo en una
especie de… Hollywood primitivo.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque Thomas Alva
Edison no estaba dispuesto a perder la batalla!
No olvidéis que tenía el dinero, la fama
y las patentes. Para que os hagáis una idea,
en menos de 5 años, Laemmle y sus socios
tuvieron que enfrentarse a más de 200 demandas
judiciales. Y muchas de esas pequeñas productoras
tuvieron que echar el cierre por no poder
hacer frente a todas las demandas que les
presentaba la empresa de Edison. Si… eran
malos tiempos para los productoras… pero
fue una época dorada para los abogados.
Por si eso fuera poco, Edison tenía suficiente
poder como para obligar a todos esos nickelodeons
de Nueva York y Chicago a firmar contratos
de exclusividad. Si querían utilizar la tecnología
de Edison, no podían comprar las películas
de la competencia.
Y fue en ese momento cuando nuestro amigo
CARL LAEMMLE se preguntó ¿Quién me manda
seguir en la Costa Este? Edison era un hombre
poderoso, sí. Pero su sombra no llegaba a
todas partes. Había un lugar alejado de su
órbita de influencia. Ese lugar era California.
EL NACIMIENTO DE UNA INDUSTRIA
En 1915, California era un sitio donde estaba
todo por hacer.
Miles de jóvenes inmigrantes,
que recordad que era el público perfecto
para los cines, llegaban cada año. Las casas
y el suelo eran sustancialmente más baratos
que en cualquier otra parte de Estados Unidos.
Y por si esto fuera poco, el clima era fantástico.
En Nueva York llueve cada dos por tres, así
que, si quieres rodar películas, tienes que
hacerlo en un estudio y gastarte miles de
dólares en focos. En California, puedes rodar
en exteriores en cualquier época del año.
En otras palabras, California era el lugar
perfecto para crear una productora. Y por
eso, todas estas productoras de Nueva York
y Chicago se asentaron en un barrio en las
afueras de Los Ángeles. Un suburbio de poco
más de 500 habitantes que se llamaba HOLLYWOOD.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo el cine de California
llegó a conquistar las audiencias del mundo
entero? No olvidéis que, por aquel entonces,
Estados Unidos todavía no era la potencia
hegemónica que sería más tarde. Además,
países como Francia o Dinamarca ya tenían
sus propias productoras de cine. Así que
¿Por
qué Hollywood logró la fama internacional
tan pronto?
La respuesta está en el llamado EFECTO RED.
Los que estáis suscritos a VisualPolitik
nos habéis oído hablar mil veces de este
fenómeno. En otras palabras, todos estos
estudios que había en Hollywood sirvieron
como un imán para atraer a inversores y profesionales
de todo el mundo.
Eso explica que en 1915, Hollywood fuera el
escenario de la primera super producción
de la historia: “El nacimiento de una nación”,
que llegó a costar alrededor de 100.000 dólares
de la época. Por cierto, que fue una película
extremadamente polémica porque, básicamente,
los buenos son el Ku Klux Klan. Pero eso es
otra historia.
Lo cierto es que, en poco más de 10 años,
la población de Hollywood creció en más
de 30.000 habitantes.
En su mayoría eran inmigrantes como, por
ejemplo, Francisco Elias.
Este español llegó
a Estados Unidos para trabajar como ayudante
de producción. Y en seguida se dio cuenta
de una cosa. SI traducía al español los
cartelitos que salían en las películas,
podía exportar cine a España y Latinoamérica.
Y al igual que él, muchos otros inmigrantes
se dedicaron a traducir las películas a sus
lenguas maternas.
De repente, el cine de Hollywood
se podía entender en todo el mundo.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque ya sé lo
que estáis pensando! ¿Qué pasó cuando
se inventó el cine sonoro?
Pues precisamente, este fue el auténtico
punto de inflexión en la industria del cine
estadounidense.
Os voy a poner un ejemplo: en la Alemania
de Hitler, el gobierno invirtió auténticas
fortunas en subvencionar a sus productoras
de cine. Y, por supuesto, estas empresas intentaban
exportar sus películas a los países aliados.
Países como la España de Franco, que durante
los años 40, era aliada del Tercer Reich.
Sin embargo, casi ninguna sala de cine española
llegó a proyectar películas alemanas ¿Por
qué?
Pues por que estas productoras alemanas apenas
contaban con la tecnología necesaria para
doblar las películas.
En cambio, Hollywood contaba con montones
de startups que se habían encargado de desarrollar
los mejores sistemas de doblaje.
Además,
al tener tantísima población inmigrante,
era fácil contar con traductores y actores.
Incluso algunas productoras llegaron a tener
oficinas en otros países como España para
enviar los rollos de celuloide listos para
ser reemplazados por audio en español.
En otras palabras, que las películas estadounidenses
eran mucho más baratas de proyectar que las
de ningún otro país.
Esto, unido al talento de auténticos genios
del cine como John Ford, que venía de Irlanda
o Ernst Lubitsch, que venía de Alemania,
fueron las armas definitivas para que Estados
Unidos desbancara a cualquier otro país en
lo que respecta al cine.
Es decir, que Hollywood
nació a partir de la gente que venía desde
fuera de Estados Unidos… y Hollywood creció
gracias a vender sus películas hacia fuera
de los Estados Unidos.
Y, por cierto, aquí tengo que hacer un paréntesis.
Si no conocéis a John Ford, haceos un favor
y tratad de ver “El hombre que mató a Liberty
Valance”. Es algo así como la capilla Sixtina
del celuloide y no ha envejecido en absoluto,
aunque esté en Blanco y negro. Es un consejo
que os damos desde VisualPolitik y que nos
vais a agradecer.
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿Qué pasó después?
¿Cómo consiguió Hollywood sobrevivir a
la censura o a la piratería? Si queréis
que os cuente esta historia, me lo podéis
decir en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, en este otro vídeo os contamos
otra historia de éxito. La historia de Apple.
Haced click aquí para verlo.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto!